So far, we've looked at a number of visualizations to examine
the distribution of a single variable. And, we also looked at
transforming a variable to get a better look at the data.
Now, there are other ways that we can transform a variable,
beside using something like the square root or a log. You
often want to convert variables that have a lot of zero values
to a new binary variable that has only true or false.
This is helpful because we may want to know whether a user
has used a certain feature at all, instead of the number
of times that the user has actually used that feature. For
example, it may not matter how many times a person checked
in using a mobile device. But, whether the person has ever
used mobile check-in. Here's what I mean. Here's a summary of
the mobile likes in our dataset. The median is four, which
means we have a lot of zeroes in our dataset. If
I run this summary, I'm going to get a different type of table.
Notice that in the table I get logical counts, because I
use this comparison operator. I wanted to see whether or not
someone had actually checked in. So, instead of tracking the count
of mobile likes, let's create a new variable that tracks mobile
check-ins. We'll call this variable, mobile_check_in. The first thing I'll do
is assign it a bunch of NA values. Next, we can
use the if/else function to assign a value of one if
the user has checked in using mobile and a value of
zero if the user has not checked in. So in
this if/else statement, if this condition is true, we'll assign our
user a value of 1. Otherwise, we'll give them a
value of 0. And the last thing I'll do is convert
it to a factor variable. Running this code, I get
my new variable saved. And then taking a summary of the
results, I can see that about 64,000 just shy of
that, have checked in using mobile while 35,000 have not. So,
using this data can you tell me what percent of users
check-in using mobile. Try to use actual code here instead of
using these wrong numbers. Round your answer to the nearest percent
and don't include the percent sign when you enter it here.